Charles Barkley the hall of famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst from inside the NBA
Chuck how are you how's vacation
vacation is lovely lovely that's it
brother
how are you better at golf or fishing oh
I'm a great fisherman I am I'm really
good I'm actually in Alabama pissing
right down
I got it I'm gonna watch a couple more
hockey games a couple of NBA games then
I'm gonna work on my golf game
you should host a fishing show there
people don't like the work they only do
it for money why do people always offer
me jobs like I know their work is very
overrated I'm on vacation for the next
four months I'm not going to do anything
but drink play golf and that's it and
fish I don't want to do anything else
I'm doing it but that's a show where you
don't do anything you can eat drink and
fish and you get paid to do it
yeah but you got cameras around you
can't use profanity did you say but you
got did you have to talk to people if I
don't wants to talk to people as they
have to stop this all right what about
this with the boxing one the janky
defense with Steph Curry and Golden
State you got a problem with that I have
zero problem with it the objective is to
win the game no they have no problem
with it whatsoever yeah I think Steph
doesn't like it because I've never met
somebody who had a box of one plate
against them where they go yeah I'm fine
with it I can't hate it because you're
taken out of the game well listen
whatever they were doing will working to
be honest did you know that's when they
made their run I mean they lost the game
in the third quarter but you know they
only made one basket like the last five
so whatever they were doing was working
period there's been so much talk and the
NBA is all about what's gonna happen
next season or in the offseason or in
free agency and we've been
with this for yeah yeah let me tell you
something I am so sick of every junkie
jackass idiot and a fool getting them TV
and radio for the last six months acting
like they know where all these players
are going to go I think all these guys
and I'm saying all of it because I mean
all of them every week a guy or somebody
told me the kids going to the big time
going to the Knicks tyrese going to the
Lakers Hawaii is going to the Clippers I
take all these guys on TV and ready or
full of scrap I don't know just throwing
stuff out there someone might get it
right but I think they're all making it
up so and then I would say well I
haven't talked to what's-his-name but I
talked to somebody this camp I'll take
all these guys just trying to be
relevant yeah that's just guessing I
don't think I'll even take the players
know what they're going to be honest
with you well I also think that
reporting now has become I'm hearing and
and you can cover your bases I don't
know who your source is and if you say
hey that's just what I heard if you know
that's my point you do watch TV for the
last all season all these things I said
exact same thing my source of what I'm
hearing I think these guys are full of
crap
I don't think these guys know anything
but like I said I want to make my point
I reach the point I don't think these
players know where they're going know
how I know that because this time full
of crap these reporters are because all
these guys are called between a rock and
a hard place we can't go anywhere by
themselves yeah that's the biggest
problem of all these guys got no matter
how great whether you talk about Kauai
painting Kyrie Jimmy Butler none of
these guys can make a move until
something happens so that's why I think
all these reporters are full of crap
Tomic they know what somebody's going
because if you go to a team by yourself
your team is not going to be any good so
that's what's going to be very
interested this summer who makes the
first move who's talking behind the
scenes because you can't go anywhere by
yourself are you gonna be on a making a
lot of money on a bad team who is more
likely to sign a one-year deal to stay
with their same team
Kauai or Kevin Durant on a poly Kevin
Durant I'm hoping Kailash stays in
Toronto it'll be graphic is great for
the league that Toronto's doing well the
wire situation is interesting because
they can't pay all those guys yeah I
mean you cuz you know you can't put a
Kevin
play and dream on I mean that's just not
going to Rick gonna work so I think just
I think it's pretty sure they don't side
and clay or trade dream on because they
can't take up all I think that's the
probably the one thing that I'm punished
show about the be honest with you
wait you think that they refined clay
they resigned Kevin and then they trade
draymond Green well I think that's part
of the best scenario you don't know
why's the inner interest Central Asia
because they don't have to have a good
team moving into that new building and
the one sure way that make sure they're
good is to reset on Kevin and clay and
dream on drugs that you can't pay all
three of those guys you can't be paying
for players 800 million dollars I mean
that just doesn't make any sense
whatsoever because that luxury tax would
be through the roof and and I know clay
three money Kevin all going 150 to 200
million dollars
you can't pay up all can the NBA
continue to do this and have these
salaries where you got guys who aren't
great and they're gonna make forty to
fifty million dollars a year
well you know then I've been saying that
for five years I think the biggest
idiots in the world are NBA owners
because you know since all these guys
want to play together now you know we
don't have any competitive balance but
these owners was making so much money
they sign this deal where we have to
paint that their teams how to make X
amount of millions of dollars and I was
saying wait a minute if all these guys
want to play together and we don't have
any competitive balance why do I have to
pay my crappy team the same amount that
the wires are paying their players so
that was a great question you asked me
I'm expecting this thing to come
crashing down soon to be honest with you
because I don't understand if all the
stars want to play together built a
super team why do I have to paid my
crappy team the same amount of money
that claim Kevin and all these other
great players are making why am i got to
pay my guys or bombs that type of money
so of course it is a hundred percent
correct I think in the next couple of
years this team is gonna come crashing
down around us he's Charles Barkley the
Hall of Famer joining a Stan Patrick
show do you think the pelicans have an
issue with the Lakers that that would
prevent them from trading Anthony Davis
there well I think it just depends on
they got to make the best deal you know
those those guys clutch really wants
really wants a B in in LA to help LeBron
but it just depends on the trade the
pelicans got to make the best trade for
them they got to take their ego out of
the equation but listen the Lakers got
to do something to help abroad and after
Davis is a hell of a player but I'm not
giving after it they was a way for trash
that's not gonna happen but this is what
happens when you trade a star player and
then you deplete the roster of the tea
he's going to are they gonna do a sign
in trade or you know because if if
you're Boston do you do a sign and trade
with Kyrie to get something the Boston
Celtics already fleets the nets a few
years ago with the with the Kevin
Garnett and Paul Pierce deal you know
are these players gonna want they're
gonna want the max money and then be
traded right nobody's going to walk away
from 40 or 50 million dollars are they
well you know that's the generation
we're dealing with now these guys want
their take it easy to you know that's
part of the worst thing we got going on
and leave the players are running the
league down well they get to dictate
where they go and so so down it's going
to be very interesting how all this
stuff goes down this summer it's going
to be one of the greenest and craziness
all seasons in NBA history I'm going to
sit back with some 1942 tequila on the
golf course or fishing and just watch
those if this is gonna be the crazy
summer ever at NBA history a little done
Julio is that what you're doing yeah
look 1942 times really as you do it big
tossed in a bottle modeled after my body
would you want to play for the Knicks or
the Lakers if those were the only two
options
that's a great question man you know I
really like Steve bills Scott Terry but
I don't have a lot of faith in Jim Tolan
to be honest with you you want to go by
somebody's track records you know that
the thing with you go the Lakers are who
I never thought I'd bet your Knicks and
Lakers in the same sentence I mean
they're both so dysfunctional i what let
me ask you a question honestly
it depends on who's going with me to the
Knicks you know I don't think you can
just go to the next but that's what I
said earlier the conversation you got to
get at least two great players
if you're going to go to the next cause
if you look KD or ty read and you go to
the Knicks by yourself you're not gonna
be any good
that's a see that's the thing I think
they'll be very interested this summer
new everybody's talked about all these
guys if you don't get two of these guys
you're not gonna be any good but I'm
trying to understand this though Charles
if Katie and Kyrie are buddies and you
know now you have some reports saying
that Kyrie is gonna go to the Brooklyn
Nets well does he know then that KD is
not going to go to the next and that's
why he's going to the Nets or well that
but see that's what I'm saying
that's why I think all these guys are
full of crap out there just get on TV
and radio every day saying what I'm
hearing from my sources or and like they
just make him stuff up listen KD or
Kyrene if they don't go together they're
not accomplishing anything if Katie goes
to the next or Kyrie goes to the next
that's not a better situation either one
of them are in right now I mean I mean
that's the fact that a matter let's see
that's the thing unless some of these
players go somewhere together they
pretty much to stay in their own
situation where they are better off I
mean okay Curry's not going to be in a
better situation than he is in Boston if
he goes to the next and same thing with
KD if he goes to the Knicks
they're not gonna be any good unless he
gets somebody to go with him but do you
really think that KD wants to establish
his own team separate from Russell
Westbrook separate from the Golden State
legacy and then really say hey I can do
this on my own I will just tell all
these day I'm hitting something
hey I've been a great player by myself
that ain't a lot of fun you know
when I got traded to Phoenix and I got
Dan Majerle Kevin Johnson mark where
says to follows that though
Oliver Billa those guys it was like I
went to heaven this notion that you a
great player planned by yourself
amen that ain't a lot of fun so I would
caution all these dudes hey the grass
ain't always greener when I was in
Philadelphia playing by myself that was
not a lot of fun so but that's a seed
that's I'm saying there and that's
what's going to be the most intriguing
thing about all this stuff this summer
these guys can't go anywhere by
themselves New York as you call it New
York find yourself in ten two hundred
million dollars if the club is mediocre
you know how the process is going to be
to those guys do you think that you were
too friendly with Jordan and the NBA
Finals when you're in Phoenix like your
buddy you know what's really about that
I have heard all these foods and
jackasses for it's over 30 years now me
and Michael never even saw each other
doing the final seminal point that we
played golf together which is not true
because the point that we had dinner
every night that was not true so the
answer to your question is that goes
back to these foods I'm listening to
they make it up stuff then Michael's
never saw each other for the finals that
is so funny man I just laughed now when
I hear what my sources are telling me I
mean I'm watching the day now see now
Kyrie Kevin affidavits gonna play
together I know with the next I think
there is a salary cap in basketball and
I don't think this can get all three of
those guys because this would have to
treat everybody on their walk listen not
only that they'd have to trade everybody
to get a TD that's right everybody on
their roster throw in Patrick Ewing and
John Starks and winners we need they
don't have enough it has no players on
the Knicks roster but I would trade for
Anthony Davis
and they're not going to get Tyree and
Cameron the red nice but that's the
stuff we have to listen to every day for
the next few months please mm-hmm hey
enjoy your vacation we'll try not to
bother you and thanks again always good
to talk to you all right my brother
I got supper bowls in his eyes there a
keeper Thank You charms it's Charles
Barkley NBA on TNT for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]